let me ask you about Joe Biden what are
the strengths and weaknesses of Joe
Biden weaknesses I think are some of the
things you've identified he has not seen
as
um high energy he is
um not the same Joe Biden that debated
Paul Ryan in 2012 and ran circles around
him in just an incredible debate
performance
uh he is not
inspiring in the way that someone like a
Barack Obama was to people coming up and
starting to get interested in politics I
think a lot of those are fair criticisms
I think on policy he's not interested in
a lot of the things that younger voters
are interested in I mentioned cannabis
reform
um I mentioned student loans so so I
think that that's a deficit for Biden I
think the upside to Biden is when it
comes to foreign policy diplomacy
high-level negotiations knowing how to
engage with allies in a productive way
it's tough to find someone with more
experience than Biden I know that there
are counterpoints to what I'm saying and
those include that was the old Biden the
new Biden doesn't have it that includes
that's just a sign of rot because he's
been around for so long nobody should be
around that long in politics perfectly
reasonable criticisms to talk about but
I do see that as one of his strengths
and he also is good at knowing when he
can work with Republicans and when he
can't
and not wasting more time than is sort
of expected for posturing reasons and I
think that that's a good thing do you
think he's actually there so in uh
day-to-day operation of government given
his cognitive capabilities do you think
he is um
uh an active and practicing executive I
don't know that I can say that it's
because of what may be going on
cognitively but my sense from the people
I talk to is that he's very much
involved in the highest level
geopolitical and big domestic economic
stuff
but that a lot of the smaller issues
that presidents might or might not be in
sort of plugged into that he's not
plugged into the the details of a lot of
the the lower level stuff yeah you could
probably apply the same exact criticism
even more so towards the Donald Trump
Administration in terms of being a
practicing active uh executive who's
paying attention like for example like
Vladimir Putin is somebody
um
who loves the the role of the executive
has a huge amount of meanings has
constantly tracking information about
agriculture and all the different
subsystems of government Stalin
funny enough was also extremely good at
this so certain people just love the job
of being an executive and I'm not sure
if Donald Trump did
um and I'm not sure if uh Joe Biden in
this current state has the cognitive
capability to that's a it's a good
question Kim jong-un's another one by
the way you know there's videos of him
uh examining a pottery you know a
factory where they make plates and
making very specific comments about how
the plates should be made I think that
in that case there's a lot of propaganda
value to it with Trump uh I think you're
probably right you know he did get
involved in the minutia of things I mean
once he pulled out a weather map and
with a sharpie drew a different
hurricane path that was more politically
convenient to him that's pretty micro
you know saying The Weather Channel I
see what you did there this is okay I
see what you did there he went to Puerto
Rico and he gave out paper towels after
a hurricane now he was shooting them
like free throws which didn't look very
good so he will get involved in the
micro when it's advantageous you know
what I mean but I do agree with you that
he wants to just kind of make it so
build the wall I don't know just build
it figure it out get it done
quick pause bathroom break sure yeah
you're hilarious
and just for the sake of completeness I
should mention the subreddit wood Biden
has done
there's also what Trump has done but
it's not as active and it has like this
master list of all the accomplishments
it's I recommend people look at it
because there's a
it's kind of rigorous and interesting
with links a list of all the things he's
done just to list some of them uh
restored Daily Press briefings uh cancel
the Keystone Pipeline reverse Trump's
Muslim ban required masks on federal
property rejoins the Paris climate
agreement extends student loan payment
freeze extend eviction freeze historic
stimulus bill as you mentioned hence
funding for border wall and so on and so
forth DACA uh border strengthening of
dot cover joins the World Health
Organization and the timing of this of
course is important
yeah several historic stimulus bills
which of course you could criticize or
support
raise the minimum wage for federal
contractors and federal employees for
fifteen dollars
there's a lot there's a lot it makes you
realize
um with both Trump and Biden that
there's a bunch of small details
that matter yeah like that matter on
people's lives like actual little
policies Trump did a lot of stuff as far
as I heard for the military like not big
stuff but small stuff
yeah I'd be curious what you're thinking
of I mean I know one of the big things
under Trump was we're going to get trans
people out of the military
uh that's not what I was referring you
aren't referring to that uh he Trump
that tells you know Trump's hilarious
with these stories that he tells and one
of the story and you get to know them if
you if you follow him at all he tells
the story you know when I came into
office the generals came to me and they
said sir the cupboards are bare we have
no bullets and so I rebuilt the military
you know the cupboards were bare when
Obama left it and it was just terrible
but I rebuilt it and the generals I've
got the best generals they said sir it's
incredible what you were able to do you
look into it and it's like yeah that's
not really true like it is true that
there are armaments that just like on a
schedule do get replaced and that's part
of the military industrial complex but
there's nothing like special Trump
really did but these stories become
they take on like a life of their own
and it's interesting to sometimes try to
dig down and figure out like was there
any policy connected to that or is that
just a story